hey everybody I'm Joanna Smith and I
work on google+ and I Wolff Dobson I
work on Android and today we're going to
talk to you about google i/o hunt which
is the game that we made for Google i/o
2013 we've just open sourced it it's at
mfc hunt appspot com and we want to tell
you about what the game is and then how
you can make your own so the game is
actually easier to show than it is to
demonstrate right here so we're gonna
cut to a clip of Joanna and I playing
this game and on the Google campus to
put up an mfc hunt we hide NFC tags and
interesting places the Hunts now set up
so joanna is gonna be our guinea pig
what I half years I've opened the app
and it's welcoming me and I'm going
through it and I'm kind of getting to
find out the story and now I've got
google has sign an option so I'm going
to go ahead and sign in so the first
thing is I get a clue and it's got an
image as well as text letting me know
where to go and since I happen to work
on this floor I kind of know the floor
pretty well so let's go take a look at
what I think these this area might be
and I was right so I can immediately see
it clues exactly what I want cemented my
MSC device let's see it and I got a paw
print because I found with the first
clue well what's really cool is I can
actually scan these in any order and
they're going to show up so that's very
awesome what we usually have one or two
ever easy to find one that's kind of
hard wolf oh and I got them all so I get
to go to the next clue picture is a
slide and let's apart my favorite part
of the floor so let's get on a slide
here we go
alright so the app back up because I
already see a clue and sure enough once
again any orders I can scan them I look
to why they're so easy so got second one
in the third but what this is a fake tag
so this is a feature that we added
that's really fun because you can throw
people off the scent and have decoy tags
all over the place and then you bring up
this little guy so let's find the last
30 p merit so now you can see once again
I'm going to get a new clue and I know
where the sign is but unfortunately I
think we're out of time so let's go back
to the studio so that was our video a
little cheesy but obviously really fun
and you can set up the game yourself in
a number of ways set it up as a race or
in teams it's pretty cool but in order
to make these changes you need to
actually see it run and see how it works
so wolf alright so as you can see we
have this intersection here and you'll
want to modify that with your own text
because you're not actually going to be
on the floor of moscone center so we're
going to import the two projects that
you download we're actually three
projects you get as we need we get
simple io hunt you get hunt writer which
writes tags and you get I Oh hon I on
tis the full version of the game that
includes trivia questions google+
sign-in game services all the things you
need we're going to do simple io hunt
which is the same thing except without
trivia questions and so forth and we're
going to import that and you can modify
all those strings and assets and
everything inside our the resources
directory in particular you can modify
the strings you can see we have lots of
strings in here all these story strings
you can edit them any way you want and
if I run this you get the base you get
the game running and it's uh it's kind
of fun I click let let's go so if we
take a look at this screen that we've
got past the story and actually started
playing the game you'll see this image
and this image is part of the clue
letting you know kind of where to go the
text might help you get
there and the picture helps people
remember oh wait I've seen that I know
where to go now but once they get there
they're going to find tags we do three
tags in the game and the tags are
actually what you need to you know scan
in order to move on to the next clue
right and so if we were to scan these
tags right now these these tags right
now you just hold it up and go boy drink
but these tags are empty because we
haven't written anything to them yet the
this tag in particular came from co vo
their custom printed with our own labels
they've got this big scan area they're
pretty neat if you want to have but
they're only right once which means
basically when you write them you can
only write ones you can't write zeros
Joanna do we have a another kind of tag
which is this all a round guy here this
one's an all-weather one that we got
from tagged stand it's rewritable which
means you can write it several times
which is great if you're experimenting
it's not so good if somebody's attacking
your tags and trying to change them in
the middle of the hunt this one's also
shielded which means you can put it
against metal these ones aren't shielded
so you have to be a little bit more
careful so uh going back to where we
were the game itself has a actually any
number of tags between one and three and
when you scan them you're finding them
and when you scan all three you'll go on
to the next clue you'll obviously want
to change that so we're going to show
you how to change this screen just using
data so if we open up this JSON file we
have a hunt object which contains a list
of clues so a clue has this display text
so in the end in this case it's saying
well you know go find this robot it's
got an image which is which will show
you how to add and then it's got a list
of tags and the tag can be any arbitrary
string I have the number because that's
easy to remember we also have a trivia
question if you're playing the full
version of the game this question is
there if you're not playing if you're
not using the full version of the game
and let's ignore this question keep
going and so we have another clue down
here this one only has one tag to find
it's pretty straightforward all you have
to do is make sure that you have unique
tag names for each thing and that you
set the text the way you want now this
Jason file ends up inside your app
inside the raw directory inside a zip
file what's in that zip file let's take
a look if we look in
hunt data you can see it's a series of
images and this Jason file and it's
actually not showing the extension but
trust me it has the extension JSON if I
wanted to add another one say off my
desktop here I have this picture of this
cool robot I can just you just add it
here and then you'll need to package it
up when you're done to packaging it up
if you have a unix-based machine you can
just run our little make bundle script
and whoops Boosh and you get a zip file
which is just the contents of that that
thing and the make model just copies it
into the right place so let's assume
we've done that we've added the zip
files now we need to write tags we come
with it comes with these utility hunt
writer and we can pull that in as well
and you can compile it yourself you need
to compile your own hunt rider because
it's going to have its own unique count
dip in it you can't that's part of it so
we're going to we're going to pull that
in grab hunt writer and there we have it
Hunter one is running looks like this oh
and right and again you're gonna put
your you're gonna put that hunt on zip
file inside raw yeah you put it right
there this is what it looks like you can
tell we spent hours and hours and hours
on that you I but if i want to write a
tag i'm going to you know click there i
just select it and then blink I've
created a tag we got to do that a couple
more times for each one of these tags
come on scan you're my best friend there
you go and I'm not gonna dome your you
want to be a right one can write my hand
if you want sure out i'll totally right
area we're going to write joanna to and
actually that's a fun thing you can do
you can make you you don't have to just
stick tags to the walls like we did in
the video we actually a during google
i/o cold actually wore a tag for a while
people have to chase around and find him
so yeah you can have a lot of fun with
this so we've written these tags but the
question is what did we actually write
to these tags we can check we have tag
info up here which is an app you can
download from the Play Store I scan this
tag
and it says you have n def data what is
that n def data it's a URI so what we're
basically doing is just writing a URI to
a tag and when you scan that tag it goes
it gets caught by the intent filter on
the app and I've actually got the intent
filter up here you can see it says when
you find an end F thing and that end F
has HTTPS and the your URL of our site
and is also looking for path prefix f if
you look over here we can we have the f
it's basically f4 find equals clue dev
for good 0 so Deb for good 0 is the tag
that we just wrote so that's what's on
the tag it's just just a URI now we can
actually play the game using these tags
that we just wrote mmm so we have it up
scan it scan it and it you can see it's
filling in the little dog prints and
when we find all three of them it takes
us to the next clue and the next clue is
the big green google sign so that's the
game what you're going to be doing then
is going around going around finding
taking pictures of the places that you
want people to go then adding them to
your hunts if you're going to be then
writing a whole bunch of tags for each
one of those places and then hiding the
tags and what we notice when we are
setting us up is if you have one really
obvious tag it lets people know that
they made it to the right place and the
other two can be hidden a little more
like hard difficulty to make it the
search more fun so one easy to hide it
worked out pretty well um we also have
one easter egg if you have a tag that's
written with the same your eyes
everything else but the tag name is
decoy you get this oh no it's a decoy
and that can be a surprise we put that
later in the hunt when people ran along
and found it though oh my gosh it's a
decoy so that's that's the whole thing
you can also try running the main the
the full experience which has trivia
questions but otherwise it's open source
we invite you guys to take a look try
making your own hunts and
play it yourself yep have a good day